well new technology at mccarran making
some big changes on how you can get
through tsa lines we've got victoria
saha joining us live from the airport to
show us what we need to know before we
fly hi victoria
well the incoming passengers here at
mccarran international have to go to go
through some new changes and changes the
next time they fly out they're only
going to have to present their id when
they go through security
all security checkpoints will have
credential authentication technology
also known as cat impacting every
traveler flying out of mccarran this
will allow tsa to scan your photo id and
confirm your flight without you having
to hand over your boarding pass
lori dankers with the tsa says this will
help add an extra layer of security to
confirm each passenger is authorized to
fly we need to know the person who is
flying is who they say they are that
they're not an imposter in any way so
the cat unit is able to detect that
mccarran is one of the few airports
across the country with this technology
and hopes to prevent fake travel
documents
so there is an exception if you're a
minor you don't have to present your id
but you do have to present your boarding
pass reporting from mccarran
international airport victoria saha live
local now